[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Osuna
is a small village
in the Andalusia region of
Spain, where the unemployment
rate is 31.5%.
But the town's fortune
changed in 2014
when the hit HBO series
"Game of Thrones"
came to film for 17 days.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANA BELEN YEBES:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
NARRATOR: The famous Daznak's
Pit scene from season 5
was filmed in Osuna's
bullring, which is now
open to the public for tours.
RAFAEL DIAZ GOMEZ:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
NARRATOR: A permanent
"Game of Thrones"
exhibit was installed at
the Osuna Museum in 2015.
JESUS CANSINO LOPEZ:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
MARIA ROSARIO LOPEZ:
MARIA TERESA JIMENEZ:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
ANA BELEN YEBES:
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESUS CANSINO LOPEZ:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
NARRATOR: Be sure to check
out this next episode
about making a living
by climbing trees
around the world.
BRYSON VOIRIN: The
most common reaction
I get when I'm on a flight,
sitting next to somebody
and they ask, what do
I do, and I tell them I
study sleeping sloths
and I climb trees,
they think it's a joke.
And then I tell them,
no, I'm serious,
and I show them
pictures on my phone.
And they're like, that is the
coolest job I've ever heard of
and how is that really a job
and how do I get to do it?
NARRATOR: And
please don't forget
to subscribe to
"Seeker Stories" so you
can see new videos every week.